Transcription: Elisabeth Buffard
Relecteur: Samira Kwache
Est-ce qu’en 2023,
il faut vraiment encore s’engager
pour l’égalité des chances ?
Est-ce que je dois vraiment encore
convaincre des personnes pour s’engager
pour l’égalité des chances ?
Pour avoir une réponse à ceci,
faisons un petit pas dans le passé.
Là, la première image, vous voyez
une des premières manifestations
dans les années 50 à Berne.
Ces femmes-là, à l’époque déjà,
elles ont utilisé l’escargot comme symbole
de la lenteur de ce progrès.
Dans les autres pays, il y avait déjà
plein de femmes qui pouvaient voter.
Ben non, en Suisse, pas.
La deuxième image, c’est Iris Von Roten.
C’est une des grandes intellectuelles
de la Suisse
qui a vécu dans les années 50-60.
Un personnage que je vous invite
fortement à découvrir.
Elle a écrit un peu la bible
pour les féministes.
En allemand, le livre s’appelle
Frauen im Laufgitter.
En français, le livre s’appelle
Femme sous surveillance.
Ça vient d'être traduit il y a deux ans.
Ce qui est intéressant
chez Iris Von Roten,
Déjà, elle avait un allié :
son mari, Peter von Roten, était
conseiller national du Canton du Valais.
Lui, il a déposé une motion
pour le droit de vote des femmes en 1951.
Vous pouvez imaginer son succès,
il était non plus réélu.
Troisième image,
c’est la grève des femmes en 2019.
Alors dans ce gap, il y avait quand même
énormément qui se sont passés en Suisse.
Et la Suisse de nouveau,
est le pays unique
où les hommes ont donné
le droit de vote aux femmes
par une votation populaire.
Seulement en 1971,
il fallait un peu du temps,
l’escargot, il est de nouveau là.
Mais c’est quand même
un cas unique dans le monde.
Aujourd’hui, on a dans la Constitution
des articles pour l’égalité des chances.
On a une loi pour assurer
l’égalité salariale.
Il y a de plus en plus de femmes
dans les postes à responsabilité,
il y a plus de femmes en politique.
Mais quand même,
la grève de femmes en 2019,
c’était quand même un peu le début
de cette vague violette.
Et pour la première fois au parlement,
on a eu 40% de femmes, presque 50%.
Mais là aussi, il faut être précise :
la majorité était au Conseil national.
Au Conseil des États,
c’est encore les hommes qui dictent.
Et la dernière image,
pour moi, l’image la plus importante,
c’est la petite fille
qui regarde vers le futur.
Pourquoi il faut encore
s’engager aujourd’hui ?
Pour moi, il y a trois raisons
pourquoi aussi les hommes,
toute la société, devrait s’engager
pour l’égalité des chances.
Je suis économiste d’entreprise,
je commence quand même
d’après, avec l’économie.
Parce que ça, c’est très important.
Simone de Beauvoir le dit,
c’est en anglais maintenant,
qu’il faut seulement
une crise économique,
une crise politique,
une guerre, que toutes ces questions
sont remises en question,
qu’il faut toujours s’engager
et toujours se battre.
Là, vous voyez un graphique
que je trouve fortement intéressant.
On voit qu’il y a un potentiel énorme
des femmes qui aimeraient travailler plus
mais qu'elles n'arrivent pas.
Pourquoi ? Quelles sont les raisons ?
Aujourd’hui, tout le monde
parle du manque de main d’œuvre.
En bas, on parle de la guerre des talents.
Comment les chefs arrivent
à garder leurs talents,
comment ils arrivent à aller
à des head hunters aujourd’hui.
Bah, il y a quand même
différentes raisons.
Encore aujourd’hui,
la conciliation de la vie familiale
et la vie professionnelle
reste très difficile.
On n’a pas assez de places de crèches.
On a de loin pas toujours
les horaires continus.
On a un système fiscal qui nous punit
plutôt que nous faire envie
de travailler plus.
Mais on a aussi
une vision de la société
qui le rend des fois pas si simple.
Alors la raison numéro un
pourquoi les hommes, les chefs,
les collègues de travail
devraient s’engager,
on a un potentiel de femmes
qui aimeraient travailler plus,
il faut le rendre possible.
La deuxième raison pourquoi peut-être
ces femmes ne travaillent pas,
je viens de dire c’est peut-être aussi
la société, c’est la vision qu’on a
vers le mariage, vers les rôles.
Alors pour moi, la deuxième raison
pour laquelle il faut voir,
est-ce que ces femmes
ont vraiment choisi le bon conjoint ?
(Rires)
Parce que la majorité, ici en Suisse, vit
dans un modèle, disons, traditionnel.
L’homme travaille à 100%.
La femme travaille à 40%.
Souvent, l’homme a un poste
qui est assez bien rémunéré,
la femme, c’est un peu le soutien.
40% , c'est un peu difficile
à faire carrière.
Avec une conséquence
qui est quand même énorme
et je me demande si tous ces couples
ont vraiment fait le calcul
et sont conscients des conséquences.
Souvent, ces couples se rendent
seulement compte dès qu’ils se divorcent.
Deuxième raison pourquoi les hommes
devraient s’engager plus
pour l’égalité des chances,
la douleur, le divorce.
C’est malheureusement souvent le cas
que dans ce moment-là,
les femmes et les hommes
se rendent compte
que l’indépendance financière
est quand même pas si simple.
Le deuxième pilier, il faut le partager.
Mais l’homme, il commence là,
à de nouveau le remplir.
Les femmes, elles commencent là.
Et doivent se stabiliser.
Le divorce, ça fait toujours mal au cœur.
Mais après on doit encore
se battre pour l'argent.
Ce n’est pas très agréable et on voit
quand même une très grande différence
si les deux sont indépendants
financièrement
que si ce n’est pas le cas,
Deuxième raison pourquoi
les hommes devraient s’engager.
Troisième raison.
Il y a quand même beaucoup plus d’hommes
qui sont pas si contents
dans ces rôles prédéfinis
d’assurer, d’assumer
toute la responsabilité
financière d’une famille.
C'est une tâche lourde.
De pas passer vraiment du temps
avec ses enfants dans le quotidien,
c’est pas si bien.
Mais quand même, on voit aujourd'hui ça.
Il faut se rendre compte en Suisse
que beaucoup d’hommes ne prennent pas
le congé parental de deux semaines.
Est-ce qu’ils se cachent au travail
ou ont peur des bébés ?
Je sais pas.
Mais on voit même que ces jeunes pères,
ils augmentent leur taux de travail.
Alors on voit quand même
qu’il y a là un conflit.
Mais souvent quand même, on voit
les hommes se posent des questions.
Cette année à Zurich,
ils ont repensé la masculinité.
Ça m’a fait un peu rire
parce que de se déguiser avec une jupe,
ce n’est pas pour moi
vraiment le féminisme,
mais ça m’a quand même
fait repenser et dire,
il y a quand même aussi des jeunes hommes
qui sont pas si prêts,
qui veulent aussi repenser ça.
Et pour moi, ça c’est vraiment
la chose claire si on veut faire avancer
la société, vers une société plus diverse,
vers une société plus égale des chances
et pas égale à tous les niveaux.
Quand on a tous les mêmes chances,
c’est seulement ensemble
qu’on arrive à faire ce défi.
On doit transformer les hommes
comme des agents d’un changement positif,
qu’ils voient que c’est une valeur
en économie, dans leur couple,
c’est une valeur ajoutée dans le privé.
Et vraiment, cette balance-là,
qu’on arrive à l’accueillir
et c’est quelque chose de bien.
Parce que le monde ne va pas si bien
à ce sujet-là.
Si en fait, on regarde
un peu plus loin que la Suisse,
On regarde l’Afghanistan,
on regarde l’Iran.
Ça fait mal au cœur.
Mais là aussi, en Iran,
si je vois ces hommes
qui s’engagent avec ces femmes.
qui sont plus prêts à vivre
dans ces conditions si strictes,
ça me rassure.
Et j’espère aussi vraiment en Suisse
qu’il y a plus d’hommes qui s’engagent
et que vous faites entendre votre voix,
que vous parlez avec votre collègue,
vos frères, vos oncles,
vos fils.
Je compte sur vous, les hommes.
Les mecs sont la clé de succès
pour plus d’égalité de chances en Suisse.
Merci.